we're joining me now is socialite and
Prince Andrew's former girlfriend lady
Victoria Harvey author and historian Dr
Tessa Dunlop and my son's former Royal
editor Duncan larkham and from America a
lawyer to 20 Jeffrey Epstein's victims
Gloria Allred well welcome to all of you
Estella panel a Gloria Allred I mean
well first of all uh lovely to talk to
you and a belated happy New Year to you
Gloria um your reaction when you heard
the Gilliam Maxwell had given this
extraordinary interview from behind bars
and I suppose more pertinently to the
content of that interview
well I think that she obviously was
trying to be helpful uh to her former
friend or acquaintance prince Andrew and
uh that that was part of her intent I
don't I can't read her mind I don't know
what her motive wasn't saying it maybe
it's because that's what she believes to
be true but it has stirred up quite a
storm but at some point we should talk
about whether there really is going to
be a trial because I have done many many
uh settlements with his attorney not
about this case although you're correct
I did represent 20 victims of Jeffrey
Epstein some of whom had accusations
against Miss Maxwell but there was a
settlement and his attorney
Andrew Butler is very very good and for
him to say that prince Andrew or to have
it suggested as a rumor that he is going
to file a lawsuit that somehow he was
pressured by his mother into the
settlement and that you know as they say
in the south in some parts of the United
States that dog won't hunt because
that's not a reason to overturn a
settlement and further likely although I
haven't seen the settlement uh most
settlements or in fact all of them that
I've ever done uh with Andrew brettler
his attorney have always included an
arbitration clause which means that he
can't just go right to trial even if he
would want to uh if he if in fact he did
file the lawsuit uh Virginia could make
a motion to compel arbitration because
always there's always been arbitration
clauses and that would mean it's likely
that the court if it's a court in New
York would compel arbitration and so
there would not be a public trial at
best there would be an arbitration okay
but but Gloria on the central point of
The credibility of his accuser there's
no doubt that the settlement of the case
with Alan dershow in which she admitted
that she'd uh you know had memory
mistakes and so on that was a serious
Dent to her credibility if you were
representing prince Andrew wouldn't you
think that actually if the main accuser
here who received this huge amount of
money if this other case has basically
collapsed on an issue of her credibility
would it not be worth at least trying to
go again
well that case ended up in a settlement
not in a verdict and the argument also
could be and of course I wouldn't
represent prince Andrew but the argument
for a plaintiff would be that
um you know that maybe she had a memory
elapse about one person and one set of
events that doesn't mean she had a
memory lapse about other events
right but it would be the last thing
which is probably listen but Glory
you're a very you're a very smart lawyer
Razor Smart I would say one of the
finest legal Minds I know if if you had
a situation like this and you were up
against it on the other side wouldn't
you think that if if her credibility was
now seriously in question if her memory
was proven to be completely wrong in
another allegation of a similar kind
would you not think that that might open
the door again
you know perhaps but I I think it's
unlikely you know in order for prince
Andrew to have a an actual try or you
know even in an arbitration he would
have to prove some kind of fraud at the
time and not only that there was a fraud
that it was that Ms that Virginia was
part of this fraud that's a very high
bar of evidence that's very difficult
for him to prove and I don't know that
he's ever going to prove it okay
interesting stuff let me come to Tessa
on this look I have a view that
the moment Andrew paid that check it was
game over in this case he can't revisit
this you know he said I'm gonna take it
all the way I'm going to clear my name
then he just caved and paid a massive
amount of money Millions we're not
exactly sure how many you read between
three and ten million it's you know take
your choice but it was millions and
millions of dollars to a woman he claims
he never met he's never had any
credibility as far as I'm concerned Why
would you pay somebody never met
millions of dollars in a sex abuse case
so you put it all together and you think
that but and it's an important but if
his main accuser the woman he's paid all
this money to has got now serious
credibility issues
why shouldn't Andrew
re-enter the legal Fray it's an entirely
separate case this is absolutely classic
people going out of their way to
discredit the victim of sex abuse
look to play Devil's Advocate people
aren't going out of their way to do it
she was discredited in her allegations
against Alan dershowitz
right but if one if an accuser admits
that she actually lied about that man
and told very serious allegations about
which turned out not to be true that's
different isn't it
I think it's really important to
remember that these girls come from
chaotic backgrounds which is one of the
reasons why it's so hard to make a case
stick which is why we all have to
remember when we've been listening to
what jerlane Maxwell's been saying this
is a woman who was called out by the
judge she was called out got notes
because you don't know anything about it
I do know quite a lot about talking
truth to power I'm sitting here on an
MDA right so I understand
I can tell you quite a lot she was
called out by the judge have you read
judge Nathan have you read Nathan have
you read half book which is a made-up
book there you go
about taking so many sleeping pills and
so many drugs the weekend at kennerton
street that her memory was very hazy she
writes up with her own hands let's
recall the Virginia
Maxwell genus and predatory is what the
judge called her and she went over one
second she went out of her way
to give jillane a 20-year sentence that
was beyond the maximum guideline that is
how important was it was extraordinary
to get all okay women talking to power
in that way okay so don't let's just
finally talking now
I'm going to be let's just be honest
language
signed his name too okay
sorry for the bad language that was
using only for that Victoria here's the
bottom line with this I don't believe
Elaine Maxwell at all right I think she
was up to her neck in it with Epstein I
think she was guilty as she was found
guilty and I find this this revision is
bleeding she's now doing is all
self-centered to try and get herself off
the rat the more interesting question
for me is Andrew because he remains it
was made to settle he didn't want to say
but he's a grown man the
Queen because he's an honorable he did
were you there in the room I mean I
wasn't there but I was told that the
queen and Buckingham Palace basically he
was forced to settle he had no choice
I mean look let's let's bring in
um Duncan here because and they
literally just fed him to the wall okay
hang on hang on I want to bring in
Duncan from a journalistic point of view
yeah if we were pursuing this as an
investigation and you had a woman who
made allegations against two
high-profile people
uh and one was a top lawyer right Alan
dershow is not any old lawyer this is
the guy who represented John Lennon and
got him from being deported right this
is a famous guy in America totally
different and no no here's my point and
she makes allegations of a similar
nature against him as she did against
prince Andrew and she's now had to drop
them drop that lawsuit admitting she may
have made a mistake in identifying him
as one of her past abusers we know as
journalists our Natural Instinct would
be to then be very skeptical about
anything else that she was saying right
well yes but I mean apart from the fact
that that this is the case just pretend
it's but just pretend it's not her just
pretend it's like a person has just done
this and has openly lied and then so
what would you think about the case with
another person do you think she's being
truthful well either lied or she opened
or she made a terrible mistake
of imagination whatever the reason she
doesn't wait a minute whatever the
reason she got it wrong badly wrong and
seriously defamed Alan dershowitz in the
process yeah and he fought it all the
way and that lawsuit's now been dropped
and that is the same woman as accused
prince Andrew yeah there are all kinds
of things that had it gone to court that
would have probably needed light shed on
them and mine or stood up to any kind of
Testament time the picture and the
authenticity of it obviously being one
of those points but also about the
involvement in newspapers more than a
decade ago when story was being
effectively sold to the Tabloid papers
which I was part of at the time and so
that would be in Britain certainly that
would put a big question mark over any
any potential victim
um but I don't think
um I don't think any of it matters if
you take a step back it doesn't actually
matter one Earth Andrew's thinking if he
is seriously contemplating reopening
this he's already been found guilty in
the court of public opinion and his
appearance on the BBC with Emily
maintenance has just has just
demonstrated yeah well that was a
complete setup
I can't even tell you what is really
behind this because you wouldn't even
understand but it wasn't a setup I mean
news and I went to him he agreed to do
an interview and he thought he said well
he basically exposed himself hideously
over an hour-long toe curling encounter
with a very smart journalist here's my
problem with Andrew about all this right
I remember when the pictures appeared on
the front page of the news of the world
of him walking with Epstein through a
path Central Park
it wasn't like he just met him in the
Park he spent four days with the guy
yeah at his Manhattan townhouse
four days and they were all partying
right lots of women seen coming and
going in that time this is after Epstein
had admitted abusing a 14 year old after
he was a convicted so here's my question
yeah is that you can get around I mean
everything else can be murky right what
I can't get my head round is Andrew son
of the queen flies to New York for a
four-day Jolly I'm sure it was four days
we do it was four days four day Jolly
with a guy who was a convicted pedophile
yeah now that alone to me yeah should
disqualify him from public life right he
can't be no I can't be a senior member
of the royal family and consult with
convicted pedophiles willingly for four
days yeah but you know we have to
remember it wasn't such a big story back
then it doesn't change the facts of what
he did the second time it doesn't change
the fact when it happened the first time
I almost didn't even believe leave it
when I first read it because it was kind
of like it wasn't on the front pages
back then Victoria what you've said
there is absolutely a classic case
don't believe it when establishment
figures do the unbelievable but what I'm
saying is you don't know about Virginia
like I followed what is today day and
night
can I no what I've got here are notes
let me tell you Andrew accepted when he
signed last year last year he accepted
that Virginia had suffered as an
establishment
and as a result of public attacks he
accepted that publicly so are you now
saying Andrew's Elias now to ascend on
that he's never admitted anything wrong
she was the victim of abuse
oh so now you're saying he's a liar the
irony is if Andrew had not settled if he
had taken it to court then actually
given the timeline of this other case
collapsing it could have been a
situation where the credibility of his
main accuser had been brought into
serious question but
in which case the whole case may have
been dropped anyway what happened with
Alan dershowitz I was I've been in
communication with him I don't know
maybe a year or so and the junior kept
delaying her lawyers kept delaying and
delaying and delaying and his health
wasn't good you know he was really
suffering and so she if you if you're
innocent why would you keep delaying the
deposition right